تصعيد جديد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه لعله
الاخطر منذ خمسه اعوام فهذه مسيرات تجتاز
خط الهدنه الحدودي وتخترق المجال الجويه
لكوريا الجنوبيه
تتوغل المسيارته اكثر فتقترب من العاصمه
سول تطلق المضادات الارضيه نيرانها لكنها
لا تسقط اي من الطائرات المغيره وعددها
خمسه وفق وزاره دفاع الجزء الجنوبي التي
اكدت ايضا ان جيشها حرك مقاتلات ومروحيات
الى المنطقه لتعقب المسيارات الشماليه
ولاحقا اعلنت صول ان احدى مقاتلاتها
المشاركه في تلك المهمه وهي من طراز كي اي
وان تحطمت في مقاطعه هونغ كونغ شرق البلاد
الاختراق الجوي ادى ايضا الى اربك حركه
الملاحه الجويه في صول فبناء على طلب
الجيش تم تعليق الرحلات لنحو ساعه في مطري
جيمبو وانشون الدوليين قرب العاصمه اذا كل
هذه التطورات لاذت بيونغ يانغ بالصمت
بينما قللت سول من قدره تلك المسيارات على
اي فعل هجومي مرشحه قدومها لاغراض
الاستكشاف والتجسس
وبصرف النظر عن واجهه ذلك الاحتمال فان
التوغل الجديد في المجال الجوي الكوري
الجنوبي يشكل اختبارا صعبا لما يمكن
تسميته سياسه حافه الهاويه التي يتبعها
الجزء الشمالي فهي قد تؤدي في اي لحظه الى
الاسوء بين الكوريتين بعد نحو 70 عاما على
انتهاء الحرب الطاحنه بينهما
وقد شهد العام الحالي مستويات تصعيد
قياسيا اجره بيونغيان سلسله تجارب على
الاسلحه كان اهمها لاختبار اقوى صاروخ
بالستيك عابر للقارات
كما اطلقت الاسبوع الماضي صاروخين
بالستيين قصيري المدى ورد على ذلك اجرى
جيش كوريا الجنوبيه تدريبات عسكريه واسعه
النطاق مع القوه الامريكيه المرابطه هناك
والتي يبلغ قوامها
28,000
و500 جندي